[Música]
[Aplausos]
en el año 2009
en un vuelo de 3 mil 300 habitantes
la habilidad amablemente cuenta sus
historias de ir y venir a eeuu
hay una cocina
en eléctrica pero no con agua corriente
ha tenido un trabajo lingüístico estoy
haciendo
me está contando están llamando de sus
experiencias con la inmigración y yo
escribo escuchando cuando de pronto
escucharon volteo jugando
sus papás de decir que pasaron
aproximadamente
el niño aparenta tener aproximadamente
dos cosas
metiendo a pierda como ha de haber sido
eso
personas
en ordes escuelas urbanas de la
secundaria
y el lenguaje de la escuela del inglés y
ahora en español a 0
y regresa con la curiosidad una nueva
curiosidad
en ese entonces hace aproximadamente 10
años
apenas empezaba a estudiar a fondo el
fenómeno de la migración del ratón
desde ese entonces he aprendido muchas
cosas
por asiento
de 2000 a 2017
más de 3 millones de mexicanos
han recordado que han sido deportados
desde 2015 el número de personas que
saben de méxico partido eeuu es igual al
número que sale de ese país con destino
a méxico o sea la terminación
y aquí en el estado de esas galletas el
número de viviendas con uno o más
migrantes del accord no ha comentado más
que en cualquier otro estado de la
república
sácate las tiene una larga historia de
migración
comenzando el siglo 19
pero en los últimos años debido a
cambios políticos
inestabilidad económica
adiós un aumento en la migración de
retorno
[Música]
pensemos en un escenario típico por
una joven maleta de carne o de cualquier
otro estado
decide ir a vivir a eeuu
el supuesto sueño americano los dos
tienen en el viaje
por el río a través del desierto
a ver
y el cansancio
con suerte llega tomás que encuentren un
trabajo
esta vez en su familia
en el trabajo en la casa también
[Música]
los niños luchan sus primeras palabras
en esos idiomas
pasen los años y ya
nerviosos los padres e hijos se despiden
en la esquina
[Música]
el día muchas conversaciones
pero también de cuenta de un hábito un
maestro una bibliotecaria
que les ha hecho sentir bien y tal vez
que habla español
pues gracias a clases especiales de ella
es como segunda lengua de las escuelas y
también programas comunitarios y el
mismo esfuerzo de los niños
aprender el beso
duré
lo escribe
tiempo
su reto musical hacer amigos como
algunos juegos hasta practicar un
deporte poco inglés
mientras tanto en la casa pero igual el
español sigue siendo el idioma
cada individuo o familia tiene sus
razones muy particulares por las que
regresamos a méxico
repatriación por ser la deportación
razones de seguridad para tener éxito
económico
personas familiares la abuelita si el
tema
de hecho
gomà genere un conjunto de esa crisis
lo que muy rara vez es la opinión de los
niños y las repercusiones que puede
haber
lo que te llamen directo su vida ya las
culturas cotidianas
después regresando
por decisión propia por forzados a
hacerlo
y si los niños
que en las escuelas públicas y privadas
de méxico hay un número reciente de
estudiantes que han tenido parte de su
educación en eeuu
como sociolingüista una persona que es
estudiante del uso del lenguaje en la
sociedad y en mi caso particular en el
ámbito escolar me indigna la idea de ver
un día el inglés es el idioma nativo y
al día siguiente
esforzarse para que algunos familiares
les funcione en él
amigo del aprendizaje
a parte de las consideraciones
lingüísticas hay otros aspectos del
cambio sociales
[Música]
y bien qué
a la clase pues yo he tenido muchas
entrevistas con ellos
y he recibido muchos de ellos y el
hígado
con convicción lo siguiente
los estudiantes en las escuelas de
linares
que ha sido parcial o completamente
elevados en eeuu
posee
fortalezas recursos y riquezas que nos
desafía
a cuestionar nuestras nociones de
bilingüismo y culturalismo y mi
nacionalidad
y nos inspiran a pensar más allá de las
etiquetas
y hablar de nuevas formas de lugar
y cuáles son estas que están sin
recursos los llamados fondos de
conocimiento
al sistema educativo y estable
han desarrollado capacidades
interculturales
algunos han vivido la delicada situación
de vinos y documentos
y tienen muchas competencias
lingüísticas y ya se están desarrollando
ahora bien
las normales de méxico las instituciones
donde la mayoría de los maestros
[Música]
y en cursos o artes de cursos donde se
preparan los maestros para cierto tipo
de universidad por ejemplo nos enseña
igual
también hay que considerar que algunos
niños tienen ciertas necesidades
especiales cognitivas o físicas
y también se toman en cuenta que la
materna de los alumnos que abren sus
hogares es uno de los ninguna de las más
de doscientas
lo bueno incluyendo la preparación de
los maestros es como satisfacer las
necesidades
lingüísticas y educativas de los
estudiantes vienen de otro país y otros
es con eso
el observar esta situación en algunas
escuelas hace que los alumnos repiten el
año para aprender el español
los estudios longitudinales sugieren que
los estudiantes están obligados a
cursar de nuevo el año
son más cercanas
a mediano plazo y sufre de problemas de
autoestima
en mi opinión profesional pasada en casi
10 años estudios
muchas horas de entrevistas con decenas
de estudiantes familiares maestras
registradores
es que el gobierno y especialmente será
educativo
tienen una obligación
una oportunidad frente a esta situación
primero hay que cambiar nuestro
pensamiento y nuestro lenguaje relación
agoten en lugar de hablar de estos
estudiantes como un problemas hay que
reconocer su valor
para sus aportaciones
sí
se requiere una atención especial a la
lectura de escritura de respaldo
en mis entrevistas me han dicho que
muchas veces sufren porque no saben bien
escribir bien el español
también me dice que es un maestro
fuera del horario escolar el apoyo
necesario para leer y escribir y qué
bueno que siempre los maestros que
quieren tomar su tiempo personal para
apoyar a sus estudiantes y realmente
pero lo que necesitamos es un esfuerzo
colectivo
y las políticas públicas
para esta ocasión
finalmente
en las instituciones superiores donde
los futuros maestros
se necesita adiciones curriculares
como enseñar
para la misa pues tenemos que pensar en
cómo enseñar
manteniendo y fortaleciendo los niveles
de los estudiantes
no es cuestión de inglés o español sino
vamos
me partió el alma cuando estaba
entrevistando a una joven el 3 mío y me
dijo carrera de 8 años llegó de estados
unidos a los años
con ella y no pudo superar una
conversación conmigo en inglés
amigos después
a madres tías hermanos primas vecinos
padres y especialmente
en esa época de movimiento mundial
que se mira de refugiados tenemos que
pensar en la educación como con un
esfuerzo global
[Aplausos]
procuremos que los estudiantes nuestros
salones
con tantas reglas historias de ambas
experiencias tanto que ofrecer y tanto
que aprender
necesitan aislados rechazados acosados o
invisibles
en lugar de pensar en ellos como
violencia como las amenazas a 300 los
gobiernos los con su gran reto de
incorporarse a una cultura y un sistema
de educación nuevo
y en lugar de cuestionar su mexicanidad
si no comen chile no sabe los días o que
si su español está sancionado con el
inglés
y les enseñamos lo delicioso de la
comida mexicana la riqueza de la
historia y el significado de los
prostíbulos en la nación sin atrás a
michelle obama
en inglés y en balde decirles
o pollos y si les decimos bienvenidas y
bienvenidos
[Aplausos]